one of our show sponsors subway would
like us to tell you about their great
footlong sub of the day deal featuring a
different footlong Subway sandwich every
day of the week for just six dollars
that's the deal right for instance on
Monday you can get a footlong sweet
onion chicken teriyaki for just six
dollars that's a pretty good deal
yeah yeah so wait so let's go to a
different subway restaurant on different
days of the week if I want to try all
the different sandwiches what no no you
don't do that at all okay but on Tuesday
I'd have to go to one subway restaurant
to get the Tuesday sub of the day yeah
that's oven roasted chicken okay but
then on Wednesday I have to go to a
different subway restaurant to get the
Wednesday sub of the day turkey breast
how do you know all this sir I gotta say
you are really over complicating this
all right you don't have to go to a
different subway restaurant on different
days of the week to get the sub of the
day there's a different $6 footlong sub
of the day every day at Subway
restaurants it's that simple wait so I
have to make the sandwich I I never made
a sandwich in my life no you don't have
to make the sandwich subway employees
make the sandwich but also how have you
never made a sandwich in your life no
how did you get this far in life without
ever once just taking some bread when
Conan come on I mean it's not his fault
he's not alone sandwich illiteracy is a
real issue every day millions of
Americans struggle to understand even
the simplest sandwich related situations
many of them wouldn't know a tuna
sandwich at $6 on Fridays from a
meatball marinara that's six dollars on
Sundays oh but now with their $6
footlong sub of the day deal the good
people at Subway are doing all they can
to spread sandwich literacy across this
great nation now millions of people can
learn what sandwiches are how they work
and
simple and delicious they can be subway
makes them you eat them it's that easy
they make them I eat them I understand
now I understand sandwiches and that
sandwich literacy
[Music]
what just perfect
you
you